hi in this video we'll talk about what
does positive anna test means and why
you should even do a anatest
so let's see when our doctor is likely
to prescribe an anarchist
it is when he or she predicts that you
might have an autoimmune disorder like
let's say lupus rheumatoid arthritis or
scleroderma but wait a second what is
autoimmune disorder
generally our body is protected by the
immune system and the immune cells such
as plasma cell secretes antibody against
pathogens let's say this virus and
protects our body from the harmful
effects of these pathogens
thereby
immune system ensures our body is always
protected our immune system does not
attack our own cell types because they
know these are the self
and they are not foreign to our body
but under certain circumstances
immune system misunderstands its own
cells as their enemy and they start
generating antibodies known as auto
antibodies against these cell types and
thereby causing a great harm to these
cells
antinuclear antibodies often attack our
body's own tissue specifically targeting
the nuclear membrane or nuclear
structures
an ana test actually detects whether
anti-nuclear antibody is present in the
patient blood sample or not
in order to do so
the technicians withdraw blood from the
patient and it's basically
a simple blood test requires less than
10 ml blood from blood to be drawn from
you so you don't need to even fast for
the ana test but what you need to know
is what to expect from an ana test
result
in most cases positive and a test means
that you might have an autoimmune
disorder so it's a screening test
but many people do have ana test
positive but are very healthy so
how to interpret the result
and in this video we'll talk
this thing in detail particularly women
which are who are older than 65 shows
elevated auto antibodies and their test
is positive for anna
but what does all these means in terms
of autoimmune disorders
let's say this is a patient who is
suffering from systemic lupus edit
matters and based on this particular
characteristic rashes
in her face you can understand it might
be a symptom of loop lupus
so in order to get 100 percent sure the
doctor prescribes an anarchist as a
beginning
so in that particular test blood samples
would be drawn from the patient the
serum would be extracted and the serum
would be added to a hep 2 cell line in a
pathological laboratory
now hip to cell line is an array of
hundreds of antigens
now if the antinuclear antibody is
present most likely these antibodies
would detect antigens present on these
hepta cell lines hepta cells are used
because they have a wide variety of
these antigens and and these varieties
are not recapitulated in many other cell
lines but luckily hepta cell line does
so we have two eye outcomes one outcome
is the patient sample has
antinuclear antibodies and second
outcome is the patient sample might not
have any anti-nuclear antibody
so obviously
the second case
the ana test would be negative and in
the first case the ana test would be
positive
so
what we do is after incubating the hep
to cell line with patient derived serum
we add secondary antibodies so let's say
particular
anti-nuclear antibody was present
and against that a secondary antibody is
used which is fluorophoretic so if that
primary antibody was present in the
patient sample only then the secondary
antibody would bind to the primary
antibody and it would show the
fluorescence
otherwise it would be washed away in the
washing stem
ultimately scientists actually
look at these particular data under
fluorescence microscope so by looking at
the cells under fluorescence microscope
pathologists can understand what is the
scenario there are many
staining patterns that can be obtained
such as homogeneous where the overall
fluorescence is coming from all the
parts of the cell there could be
speckled pattern where the fluorescence
is like highly dot-like structures
there could be peripheral ring-like
structures and nucleolar structures
present
from the
all these are possibilities that one can
see from an artist
there could be no fluorescence at all
that's a negative test
now let's see what does this ana pattern
means
in all these circumstances we can
understand the anna test is positive
so looking at these test results and
looking at the clinical uh databases
pathologists can comment on what
possible disease might be there
but it's not a sure short
uh confirmatory test it's basically a
screening and an assumption
further tests are required for example
if you have a homogeneous ana pattern
then it might be sle might be dearly
might be rheumatoid arthritis as well
but if the pattern is speckled most
likely it could be also mctd scleroderma
or even systemic lupus
so
further tests are required so all these
patterns help us to get some lead or
some idea that what further test should
be done
to get a confirmatory result
so what we understood from these
discussion that anna is basically a
screening test it's not a confirmatory
test for any disease it only tells us
that you might have autoimmune disease
or might not because we also saw that
anapositive test doesn't mean that you
are having an autoimmune disorder
while any test can confirm specific
antibodies
it can rule out some other disease that
you are not affected by this and that so
it's kind of a good screening method
further test need to be always done
along with anna to predict one
particular type of disease
so these are the cautions that one
should understand while interpreting the
anna data and getting depressed
so if you like this video give it a big
thumbs up don't forget to like share and
subscribe please share my
channel with your friends support me on
patreon if you're an indian viewer you
can support me on bim upi app my courses
are also present in india's biggest
online learning platform that means
unacademy you can use my code ap 10 to
get a 10 discount on all my courses see
you in the next video